[Music]
it took us out of our comfort zone it
took hiphop out of his comfort zone
Diddy is keeping it real when it comes
to his decades-long career specifically
when it comes to his most memorable
wardrobe choices what was your favorite
fashion moment through through your
years I probably say the shiny suits I
call all the shots with all the spots
rock all the rocks the top all the top
it was cool for the video that's what
being an artist is about is also getting
uncomfortable and being fearless enough
to do things like that but there's a
different look from the 2000 Grammys
that change the fashion game forever
you saw that Green Versace dress that
Jayla warped for any of us when she came
out what did you say when you saw that
dress for the first time just wow what
we were all having a such a great time
in fashion and pushing the fashion
envelope ting and then we were just
stepping up our game I thought it was
gonna really change the game you know as
far as for her in fashion but um I
didn't know how big it was gonna be but
it was a great moment for it she
deserves she wanted to fly us out there
yeah well she thinks that of you too she
named you one of the great loves of her
life which I did one of yours too yeah
we got it down up next for the Mogul his
documentary can't stop won't stop a bad
boy story which chronicles Diddy and his
record labels rise to fame new music in
the show he was making music that was
making the ground shake
parfaits the whole thing is a sense of
pride I was able to make that dream come
true with the help of this whole cast of
talented people
I couldn't did it without
[Music]
you